in 1974 the discovery of a three million
year old female that walked on two legs
rocked the world researchers knew her as
al two eight eight one two the public
she was simply Lucy scientists tried to
piece together a picture of her life she
likely slumbered in trees and some think
she might have died after falling from
one but questions remain about her
species Australopithecus afarensis
namely how similar was its brain to
modern humans and did it grow up as
quickly as chimpanzees or did they take
longer to reach adulthood like human
children new research published in
science advances provides insights into
what we share and what we don't with our
famous ancestor a long-standing debate
among anthropologists is whether
afarensis is brain was organized more
similarly to humans or apes one
indicator of that difference is the
lunate sulcus a fold of tissue toward
the back of the brain in Apes this
particular fold is very pronounced while
in humans it is nearly vanished
this evolution and brain reorganization
could be linked to more complex
behaviors seen in humans like vocal
communication since the brains of Lucy
species he composed a long time ago past
researchers struggle to find marks of
these features in the interior of
fossilized skulls researchers have now
found clear impressions of the lunate
sulcus and two high-resolution scans of
afarensis skulls they indicate that the
brain arrangement in Lucy species was
more similar to Apes than humans these
detailed images of the skull and of the
fossils teeth were also used to examine
the rate of brain growth they found that
the toddler known as the de Kika child
was two point four years old at death
and that her rate of growth was as fast
as a chimpanzees but when researchers
compared the cranial volume of adult and
toddler specimens they found it took
longer for the afarensis to develop
adult sized brains than chimpanzees
our closest living relative adults from
Lucy species had 20% larger brains than
chimps while the children had brained
smaller than average chimpanzee toddlers
this means that the length of brain
growth in Lucy species was closer to
humans who are the only primates with
teenagers this longer period of
childhood learning could have
contributed to more advanced cognitive
development the longer period of brain
maturation in Lucy species challenges
the obstetric dilemma hypothesis of the
1950s
humans need narrow hips to walk upright
efficiently so some researchers at the
time proposed that humans give birth to
babies that grow outside the womb for
longer in order to preserve a smaller
birth canal but despite how easy lucy
species could give birth they still had
younger more dependent infants this
means longer childhood may have been a
solution is something other than upright
walking like social behavior development
in the future researchers plan to use
these extremely detailed skull scans to
understand how the phase changes during
development from Australopithecus
afarensis to chimps to humans these
pieces are coming together giving us a
more complete picture of our ancient
ancestors